oh hi we're here at nintendo's media
summit in San Francisco now last week we
talked about a lot of the hardcore games
the company is bringing out but it's
still Nintendo and they've still got a
lot of casual products like this cooking
trainer for the nintendo DS we're going
to talk about that and a few other
casual games this week on game line this
is animal crossing city folk the third
game in the Animal Crossing franchise
and this is going to be on the wii and
it's coming out in november 16th so in
animal crossing city folk it's going to
be familiar some aspects of are
definitely familiar like the other
animal asking games that we've seen
before so you it's very relaxed
environment you're customizing your own
town you're on a real-time calendar and
it's all about communication and making
the game your own but the added addition
to this is this the aspect of the city
so now you can actually get on a bus
whenever you want travel to the city and
there's a whole nother world to explore
there and we have the we speak which is
a microphone that sits on top of your TV
social Mike so actually it's connecting
four rooms of people instead of just one
to one connection and through that in
social play animal crossing is a really
good you know melding of the two and
that's going to be bundled with animal
crossing when it comes the animal
crossing world is your limit it's really
what you make of the game that makes it
fun for you so if you're home from work
and you want to bliss out and go fishing
for two hours do it if you want to get
furniture and deck out your house to
make it look beautiful then do that you
know it's definitely what you want to do
and if there's no really no limits and
no formula to the game this is we music
it's a very different kind of music game
than all the other music games we've
been playing all these years instead of
playing the songs the way the game wants
us to play it playing to ask or trying
to be perfect in the way that game wants
you to in a wii music you pick one of 50
songs over 60 instruments you change the
tempo you customize a number of things
to make the song sound the way you want
it to sound now that doesn't mean
there's no challenge because like
playing a real instrument and playing in
a real bad there's a lot of technique
you can bring to the song based on the
way you want to play the song now one of
the most important things about wii
music is the easiness with which you can
just pick up a range of instruments just
pick them up play them mitt by mimicking
what you would do in real life so for
instance i'm going to take us into the
legend of zelda see one of the 50 songs
i'm going to choose the concert hall now
this is going to take us to the
instrument selection screen and the band
apart selection screen there are six
parts to the band now i'm going to
choose the melody but the part harmony
would back me up to percussion parts
would back me up the bass and the core
girls everyone sort of backs up the main
a melody roll so the easiness of
instrument play let me show you how
woodwinds and presents
I will select I will take over the
melody roll simply by pointing at it
looking I've got the trumpet in my hand
the way you play a lot of these styles
of instances you use just the remote
we'll get to the nunchuck with other
instruments you basically hold it like
you would be holding the real instrument
trumpet
now when you're done playing a song you
can record a video of it that adds in
camera angles audience then it's really
like watching a music video you can then
watch all those music videos say in your
top ten it just loops all those throws
if it's your own music channel you can
also send those videos to we friends who
can then reply don't just watch those
videos or take that video data put it
into their jams and if you've taken all
this time to layer out the six pieces of
the band going in again and again
layering out a whole band even all by
yourself or with friends and family you
can then take that video data and then
change parts of the band what meat we
music does is makes picking up the
instruments easy it makes playing the
instruments easy at that point it's all
about you and what creatively you bring
to the game and the technique that you
bring to seeing your musical vision
through to the end today I'm demoing a
personal trainer for Nintendo it's a
personal trainer cook program that
basically walks you through how to be a
chef it's pretty simple actually you
pick your recipe that you want to make
and you know if you like seafood or
chicken or whatever or whatever you plan
on cooking for dinner select your recipe
it gives you a list of ingredients you
need to have on hand a list of equipment
that you'll need to prepare the dish and
then it just walks you through the whole
process from preparation cooking and
finishing it responds to voice command
it it helps you if you need more
information you can get more information
on details on how to clean fresh trout
or how to clean soul or you know even
simple things like peeling vegetables
it'll give you more information if you
need it so I wouldn't buy one for a
kitchen though it's more I think more
for somebody who wants to be a Shaffer
wants to learn how to
pizza too great tool it's designed as if
you're in a culinary school it shows you
step by step so it's very very designed
to training you how to cook like a chef
I don't know that it's a game I think
it's fun to use I think it's you know so
if it's fun I guess it is in ways a game
but it's more it's more like a trainer